So for the next part of the course, we're
going to talk about one of the ways that
most people use math really frequently,
and that is with money. Now even though
these dollar bills came out of my pocket,
we're not going to talk about my personal
financial situation. Instead, we're going
to talk about the financial situation of a
pretend startup called Gleaming Glasses.
Now this story may not be entirely fact
based, but the same principles and the
same math, that we'll talk about in
regards to Gleaming Glasses, apply to
businesses in the real world too. My
friend Grant kept getting tired of having
to clean his glasses. It was really
tedious and frustrating. He'd have to take
his glasses off of his face to clean them,
which means that he could never really see
how clean he was getting them in the first
place. One day while in the car, Grant had
an epiphany. If windshield wipers could
clean his windshield so well, why not just
make windshield wipers for glasses? But
Grant had a problem, he didn't have very
much money. So Grant decided that he would
pitch his idea to a venture capital firm.
Basically, a venture capitalist is a
person who invests money in brand new
companies that don't have enough money on
their own to do what they want to do.
Grant's glasses wipers idea was so awesome
that he received $3,000,000 from a venture
capital firm. Now, what matters isn't just
how much money Grant got initially from
his funders though. What he really cares
about at any given time is how much money
he has left over.